[Musique]
et bonjour à tous salut Livi j'espère
que tu vas bien que tu es en forme ça va
bien ça va bien merci et toi bah écoute
moi ça va on est prêt pour pour la
finale du grand événement du qu'est ce
qu'ils Championship et
donc kerwana contre donc Carolina qui
doit faire l'exploit de gagner deux
parties d'affilée dans ce match de match
pardon d'affilée donc je rappelle que
les matchs c'est des matchs en 4 parties
quatre parties donc deux blancs de noir
et il faut arriver à 2,5 pour gagner ce
match en cas d'égalité on aura un
Armageddon et il faut qu'il gagne
absolument le premier match pour pouvoir
gagner une deuxième en gros si il perd
le premier c'est terminé et Abdou aurait
fait un énorme tournoi en gagnant tous
ces matchs en fait
c'est ça et c'est juste c'est juste
complètement complètement fou attends
complètement fou un devoir que Abdou qui
passe à 100% ici donc bien sûr Abdou
c'est un des meilleurs joueurs du
circuit de la compétition mais c'est
vrai quand même que
je trouve que c'est quand même à moitié
une surprise de le voir en fait tout
et en plus
[Musique]
tu as pas des Charlots en face oui
donc non c'est ça mais en fait il y a
une toux tu as l'impression qu'en fait
ben quand il joue tout est facile en
fait bon après c'est souvent
l'impression des joueurs très forts je
regarde
pas si dur ce qui fait oui bonne chance
pour le faire c'est clair tu as
l'impression que qu'est-ce qui fait
c'est facile et qu'en fait ouais tu
pourrais faire la même chose contre le
même genre le problème c'est que quand
tu vas jouer qu'on guérit tu vas voir
que ça va pas être pareil en fait et
tu as l'impression que Abdou il fait un
petit peu enfin en tout cas moi c'est
l'effet qui me qui me donne si oui on
peut on peut regarder le bracket que
j'ai que j'ai ici sous les yeux et vous
le montrer pour que vous puissiez voir
un petit peu
le parcours un peu des deux joueurs donc
on a abstrov qui a éliminé Jules dans le
premier tour en quart de finale ensuite
il a éliminé carvana qui a grillé son
joker lors de ce match et ensuite vente
forest pour maintenant être en finale
tant que Caravana a commencé contre
shimanov donc un gain à peu près
tranquille et ensuite contre shimana
fait ben pardon la cabane a perdu
un et demi de et demi contre un
et en perdant et ben il a joué contre
firouza 2-0 après la joue contre Jules
Moussa il a gagné en Armageddon hier et
ensuite il a battu ventes forest de 1 et
maintenant il va jouer la partie
revanche contre abuse de Rohff en fait
c'est marrant parce qu'ils ont à peu
près les mêmes joueurs ils ont joué
Jules tous les deux ils ont joué tous
les deux ce sont joués déjà et en fait
il a juste battu firousan en plus un
Caravana shimanov donc il a quand même
fait quasiment deux matchs en plus et
bon c'est le prix à faire c'est le prix
à payer pour avoir été éliminé et
pouvoir revenir en finale donc voilà on
va revenir sur la scène des parties les
joueurs qui vont qui vont qui vont
bientôt commencer car voilà qui n'est
pas encore installé
et j'attends j'attends ouais bon bah on
avait dit ça commence à 5h mais on sait
que toujours un petit
un petit délai on a vu qu'il y a pas
longtemps Abdou qui a montré la caméra
enfin qu'à montrer chez lui un point
être sûr qu'il ne triche pas et tout ça
donc bon toutes les mesures en vitrine
on regarde enfin il doit montrer enfin
d'ailleurs en permanence son écran
donc son écran d'ordinateur il est bien
sûr un seul écran d'allumer et bon pas
de téléphone tout ça et une caméra
derrière aussi qui filme enfin qui filme
de dos pour qu'on voit bien un peu ce
qu'il fait ou il regarde tout ce qu'il
fait et qui filme aussi la pièce là où
il est donc c'est des mesures enquête
riches bah écoute je trouve ça bien
qu'on instauré ça parce qu'il y a des
joueurs qui
qui qui peuvent
passer
qui d'ailleurs au rétrécié dans le passé
donc on va pas en dire plus pour
l'instant mais le truc c'est que de
toute façon même en faisant ça tu es pas
sûr mais plus tu prends disons de
mesure et plus tu rends la vie chiante
aux gens plus ils peuvent se tromper à
un moment être inconfortables et se
faire choper en flag donc de toute façon
je pense que c'est bien de voilà qu'on
est précautions mais oui bon je pense
que si quelqu'un veut vraiment tricher
de chez lui il peut manigancer un truc
ça doit pas être impossible ouais non
mais en plus l'idée aussi c'est c'est le
fait de mettre ses règles là
tu as moins envie de le faire quoi tu
vois c'est même pas le fait que tu vas
prendre en flag quelqu'un ou quoi bon
même si ça peut être une chose mais le
but c'est essayer de faire en sorte que
les gens n'aient pas envie d'essayer etc
parce que mais après tu vois le truc
c'est tellement d'argent dans ces
tournois ouais après ben oui ok
c'est c'est humain de un moment
tu fais ta connerie quoi
[Musique]
et donc voilà donc c'est bien et même on
pourrait être un live moi je suis
content que
yes ce délai j'espère que ça sera
instauré deux partout et comme je te dis
moi ça me dérange pas s'il y a même une
heure ou 30 minutes
parce que toute façon quand tu es
spectateurs
tu t'en fiches quoi dedans une
demi-heure de retard par rapport au vrai
réel par exemple personne va te spoiler
le résultat enfin ça va quoi
dire ce sera un match de foot bon dès
que tu te connectes quelque part tu sais
que ils vont parler de ça coupe du monde
bon tu peux pas trop mais là franchement
le droit de charger aux échecs sur une
lumière de retard
ça va aller donc voilà donc toutes ces
mesures qui sont faites bon on a vu dans
les grands tournois aux Olympiades tout
ça
sont bon c'est quand même bien et bon
même si ça peut pas non plus tout
empêcher je pense que c'est vraiment pas
envie et que tu peux toujours le faire
mais bon encore une fois c'est c'est
c'est peut-être triste tout ça
mais
[Musique]
mais voilà toi dans ce tournoi bon on va
quand même que les meilleurs joueurs un
peu du
circuit sont quand même en finale donc
on avait quand même enfin moi j'avais
quatre favoris dans ce tournoi 24
favoris
4 vraiment joueur que je voyais voir
donc tu avais bien sûr les carreaux
un des meilleurs joueurs mais c'est vrai
que là dernièrement il est pas trop en
forme
et puis on avait aussi les deux joueurs
qui sont au final c'est quand même pas
des surprises non non
quand même c'était pour moi le grand
favori quand même sur internet c'est pas
malade tout ça et après bon bah tu as
les raisins et tu as fait deux jours qui
sont au final pour moi c'est des joueurs
qui qui
sont pas là au hasard quoi
donc on a la première partie qui a
démarré Fab avec Abdou avec les Blancs
lors de cette partie donc c'est une
sorte de ragozina
en fait avec le fond en B4 qui fait
un mélange de candidats
comme ça
souvent donc bon je suis pas du tout un
spécialiste de cette position
mais
bon c'est les positions qui sont jouées
au niveau enfin sur des quatre on joue
quasiment que ça gambida
je crois que c'est les trois grandes
ouvertures sur des 4 ans
ouais ouais
un peu
mais sinon
tu verras pas les stands tu verras pas
de Banco tu verras pas de truc un peu
freestyle Benoni d'ailleurs on a parlé
de la pédonie on a fait un super short
tu as dû le voir
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu penses d'ailleurs de la
bénédonie encore
c'est pas c'est pas une super ouverture
en fait c'était intéressant bien sûr
mais à haut niveau non c'est trop dur
c'est un jeu vous le verrez jamais en
fait ils doivent jouer pour le gars ils
peuvent
surprise mais il a joué tout le temps
non
mais en plus au-delà de ça c'est juste
que en plus les autres ouvertures sont
plus simples quoi
je veux dire si ça se trouve tu peux
égaliser avec les indiens ou quoi mais
en fait tu as besoin de te prendre la
tête à aller là si tu dois égaliser
c'est leur but tout le temps en fait
autant je veux des Nimes zodium accepté
oui ça doit être là c'est plus de
désouverture
je pense à au niveau pour surprendre tu
vois parce que bon tu peux jouer la star
bon tu as
casse pas
à l'époque il y avait quand même bien
bien dire
la popularité ça dans leur temps et
mais c'est que maintenant que nos
ordinateurs latinienne c'est dur mais à
haut niveau après un niveau amateur
enfin moi je la joue je suis très
content ça se passe bien
[Musique]
donne plus d'eau blanc vas-y on va jouer
je vais attaquer ton roi moi de toute
façon c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse donc
on verra bien on est humain on n'est pas
on n'est pas des joueurs professionnels
enfin toi tu tu vas mettre donc tu es
quand même tu es quand même là mais on
n'est pas 2006 2007 plus quoi donc
[Musique]
c'est pas
important
je vais être déçu
bon après j'ai le droit de changer une
fois de temps en temps mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que j'ai j'aime beaucoup les
stands et je la jouerai parce que je
trouve que c'est une belle ouverture
mais après au niveau bon ben les
ordinateurs les joueurs ils ont analysé
ça et tout et c'est vrai que c'est
devenu difficile à jouer je pense qu'une
des dernières semaines que j'ai eu toute
ma vie c'était je crois que c'était de
Nakamura
Nakamura SOS je crois pas avec un roi
qui était parti en G5 en roi blanc je
possède un truc je sais plus
d'un accueil avec les Blancs qu'on me
greatue aussi
galéré avec les Noirs pas forcément vu
qu'il a perdu mais elle était dure la
partie et
non ok on envoie de son temps mais c'est
vrai que comme dit les autres sont plus
simples
après ça dépend comment ça se passe
généralement il y a aussi du bon pour le
reparte souvent il faut le chasser là on
l'a pas chassé il est parti de lui-même
parce que des fois
il traînasse en B4 en l'air et
bon enfin là en même temps pour
l'instant c'est pas de fin là il part
vraiment du même pour partir de lui-même
mais
une fois qu'on a rocky avec les Blancs
qui passent quoi
on est content aussi de d'avoir accoubé
4 d'avoir placé ce cavalier en C3 et le
fond en D2 des fois par exemple on
voudrait plutôt mettre bon le fou
ailleurs ou le fond des œufs ou qui
avait fin tu vois il y a plein de
placements de pièces possibles pour les
pour les blancs alors faux B4 maintenant
te dit ben tiens déjà juste choisi un
truc et en fait là après faut que j'ai 5
H6 ou des deux
pas je veux dire peut-être que
maintenant que j'ai
menacé on va dire de manger C3 ou quoi
peut-être que maintenant qu'il a joué E3
on sait que par partir enfin je veux
dire tu vois une fois
il est rarement trop bien il serait
mieux là si on a pu faire B3 tous les
deux dans cette position mais bon bah
c'est fait c'est fait et ben je pense
fabieno de toute façon il reparlera des
6 parce que il veut jouer avec eux 5
avec probablement des pensées 4 avant ou
tu peux aussi penser à faire 5 de
toi-même
mais voilà en fait les blancs sont
commises avec un
avec ses couleurs donc maintenant ce
four que le job ici là bien embêté les
blancs avec ce schéma de pièces tu vois
peut-être que maintenant il a considéré
que le fou était bien en
D6 ouais ben voilà voilà pour faire E5
ou C5 d'ailleurs bon vu que je sens que
c'est pas plus pour ces 5 d'ailleurs que
5 mais vouloir
mais clairement le foot des deux oui il
sera en B2 il serait mieux parce que
même qu'on ne sait 5 du coup quand ça
s'échange tu rayonne sur la grande
diagonale donc c'est souvent un
accomplissement pour les Noirs d'avoir
provoqué ce fou des deux alors après
pour le coup moi je connaissais pas le
fouger 5D
en général sur H6 les blancs bah soit
herculé soit ils échanges avait abscisse
et donc ce stade aller-retour
ouais bon le problème c'est que moi je
suis pas un expert de D4 avec les Blancs
et côté noir je m'arrête indienne donc
après c'est des possibilités qui me
dépassent mais
longtemps moi si en fait tu as envie de
mais là d'avoir joué comme ça et d'avoir
donné htseau noir je comprends pas trop
quoi
et probablement que c'est pas une idée
de génie parce que là je crois que les
Noirs tout va bien enfin je veux dire ça
m'impressionne pas de voir ce que les
bons ont fait dans cette partie non
absolument pas bah c'est 5 là les Blancs
ont fait on fait enfin les noirs on fait
le plan juste basique moi c'est ce que
je montre un petit peu mes élèves sont
un peu débutants je leur montre un petit
peu de pyramide tu vois avec le pont et
tu mets le cavalier le cavalier le fou
le fou et tout ça et là c'est exactement
tu vois il a fait le plan très facile
avec les noirs et écoute j'ai
l'impression qu'il a qu'il a réalisé
déjà avec les Noirs au moins quoi au
moins ouais peut-être même mieux
donc
il voulait pas laisser en F3 donc
normal mais ouais donc ça va pas mal
pour sa vie
qu'est-ce qu'on fait là ce qu'on mange
faut prendre faut prendre et on prend
des quatre en fait je sais pas comment
évaluer cette position
ça se trouve ça donc
pourquoi je prendrais pas je sais pas
c'est juste superficiel ce que j'ai
raconté mais j'ai pas envie d'ouvrir le
fou des deux quoi alors peut-être plus
tard je le ferai s'il me fait ces trois
il me faut de choses mais là de moi-même
je me dis tiens pourquoi le faire quoi
donc pourquoi pas c'est 7 pour tourner 8
pourquoi pas qu'il y a F6 gagne un temps
pourquoi pas regarder le 5 moi j'en sais
rien en fait mais
ok mais je sais pas après bon à prendre
en D4 et eux prend des j'ai l'impression
que j'ouvre la tour 1 j'ouvre le fou des
deux et peut-être que je donne un pion
passé potentiel mais franchement bon
après je vais à cette position je serai
pas trop inquiet avec Léna pour autant
mais j'essaie d'optimiser de me le
garder sous le coup de se laisser
prendre des quatre ben j'ai l'impression
que ça a pas disparaître dans la
position
et que peut-être je peux faire d'autres
choses avant
mais bon voilà après toute façon
les échecs il faut quand même réfléchir
et jouer un peu de malheur concrète donc
là tout ce que je raconte c'est bien
beau mais si ça se trouve c'est la
meilleure manière de jouer parce que
parce que ça marche et voilà quoi
en fait moi juste mon bon mon instinct
me disait que c'est clair soit toujours
sur le pion qui sont pendant
mais bon pendant c'est pas forcément une
faiblesse ça peut être des fois une
force comme tu l'as dit j'arrive plus
tard à
avoir un pion passé et ce qui mange pas
du piano tu auras plus isolé c'était par
rapport à la structure et je pense
qu'ils doivent prendre du pion ouais je
pense tu as pas le choix une fois que tu
es là dedans et en plus c'est vrai que
cette position en fait avant de manger
en de 4 le jour où tu mangeras en rendez
4 si jamais ça se passe et ben tu
comprends toujours du bien en fait donc
tu as le temps de le faire quand tu veux
c'est vrai
mais bon après toi je sais pas à quel
point on va optimiser avec DMC 7 ou quoi
enfin si ça se trouve
ici je peux jouer aussi des coups comme
dessin pour avoir un peu passé
à passer protégé par le plan C4 plus
tard
mais je crois qu'ils sont des 5 on est
sur 10 chasser la dame et faire le 4
lui-même
assez vite enfin dès le prochain coup
quoi c'est clair pas beaucoup de cases
et puis ça donne la belle diagonale du
foot ici sur H2 peut-être des quais G4
de damage 4 des tours 5 tours je sais
pas quoi ça j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il
fait donc en gros je crois que les
Blancs faut pas faire des cinq là-dessus
à cause de ça
et faire autre chose mais
c'est bien pour pour Caroline la
position je pense qu'il est pas mal du
tout il y avait un vis-à-vis là déjà
alors là il menace quand même de manger
une pièce et pour le défendre il va
falloir que je bouge madame est-ce que
tout aussi c'est un coup
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à sortir ce fou quoi
en fait on aimerait bien il manque
aussi c'est un peu superficiel un petit
peu
dommage quand même parce que j'ai envie
quand même je pense de bon j'ai envie de
l'envoyer à quatre
c'est la photo village le cadre
ça peut être vraiment pas mal
donc salut à tous sur le chat merci pour
le petit message bienvenue à tous
j'espère que vous allez bien
donc là on est final du de la cheesed
enfin du
et entre Abdou et karwana donc c'est la
première partie le score et le 0-0
et d'ailleurs j'avais une question
passée pourquoi Carla le rendu le
cheesed mais en fait c'est pas ton nom
pour les enfants c'est juste le nom du
tournoi et cheesed c'est
une sorte d'appli ou de sites de
cheeseccab en fait qui justement aide à
apprendre à jouer aux jeunes et
d'ailleurs il est pas mal si vous devez
initier des enfants peut-être on peut
l'utiliser
et
donc voilà mais c'est tout tu peux avoir
de vétérans qui jouent ils ont le droit
quoi oui c'est pas du tout parce que les
enfants quoi c'est que le nom du sponsor
c'est le tournoi
et tout ça quoi donc 4 peut-être ou
alors regarde cavaler des deux c'est
sûrement ce qu'il veut faire
il va avoir cette case
[Musique]
c'est impossible
j'aime bien les Noirs mais
un truc c'est que si tu arrives enfin si
ton attaque te donne rien et ça peut ne
rien donner les bons le droit de
défendre après tu peux avoir à 4 à 5
avec ce petit pion passé
et tu crées des problèmes sur la chaîne
de pur inverse donc disons les blancs
ils sont pas encore d'arguments c'est
pas top top ce qu'ils ont fait mais bon
en fait ils sont pas vraiment moins bien
quoi
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je crois
plus ou moins ça non c'est 3 il y a eu
E4 qui est des deux thoracique mais
c'est la partie c'est exactement la
position qu'on a à l'analyse qui a été
joué
c'est ça OK
et donc alors est-ce que
j'ai vu le 4 mais je pense que je pense
que Valou vous proposer quatre là mais
je pense que j'encaisse le reste en fait
je pense que tu m'ouvres mon roi mais
j'ai l'impression quand même faire ça à
ça mon roi il est totalement à ma souris
moi totalement sécuritaire en fait c'est
moi qui vais te mater et j'ai un peu
plus
en fait c'est
beaucoup de joueurs amateurs qui croient
vraiment accomplir un truc énorme en
doublant un pion devant le roi et en
fait ça a vraiment dépendre des cas de
figure c'est pas toujours le cas si vous
avez suivi le match Ding nepo j'ai eu
des quatre figures comme ça
[Musique]
et
ça marche pas toujours enfin en gros en
fait clairement le roi blanc là dit
exposé mais si les Noirs vous utilisez
pas cette colonne pour vos propres
pièces en vous envoyez un de
caisse blanche vous pouvez mettre le
fond H3 ouais ça serait dangereux pour
les blancs parce que la case G2 on aura
accès ça pourrait faire un appui pour la
dame etc mais là en fait c'est des
blancs prolon qui vont utiliser cette
colonne à faire roi H1 et tourgers donc
c'est plus eux d'ailleurs qui vont
attaquer que les noirs et en plus vous
avez un pion pour faire ça donc
il faut voir aussi l'activité que
derrière quoi si tu peux tout ça pour
pour ouvrir le roi lent mais que tes
pièces ben ça va rien et ben en fait mon
roi tranquille un peu peur donc donc
voilà c'est vrai que là dans cette
position
ça vaut pas le coup de jouer à même si
ça se regarde mais après on voit que ça
marche pas on passe à autre chose quoi
autre chose voilà donc elle est deux
tours c'est vite c'est la partie
tu veux pas perdre
et il va quand même la H5 il va venir
manger 5 et il va il va balancer il joue
pour attaquer
donc
c'est intéressant il y a plein d'idées
là d'attaque en tout cas alors peut-être
qu'il va passer la dame d'abord
une fois qu'il passe la dame il peut
aussi passer la tour ça va tu as tout le
monde qui arrive
c'est bon c'est hyper logique mais en
même temps tu prend le risque de
peut-être perdre avec les noirs
on en a parlé de cette rupture à 85 si
je mangeais à 7 il y a B c'est ce qui
m'en a je peux aussi des fois pousser
des cinq et me créer un peu masser
protégé qui peut être très fort sur le
long terme au final donc en fait
concrètement la position noire elle a
l'air pas mal du tout parce que il y a
une attaque ça a l'air sympa mais si
l'attaque enfin si les blancs arrivent à
bien défendre ben j'ai l'impression que
oui finalement les blancs sont mieux
quoi
en gros voilà c'est pas clair
maintenant mais juste pour expliquer
ou passer par une autre colonne bon mais
bon c'est pas si c'est simple
c'est mon coup moi je pense tu peux le
faire enfin tu vois les mains point
d'interrogation mais je vois pas trop de
mal après bon bien sûr on n'aime pas
trop le cahier des deux qui est une
pièce plutôt passive
[Musique]
voilà F5 R4 ça peut être une menace une
fois un modèle je pourrais ramener
madame tomate par exemple si tu aimais
j'arrive à pousser F4 ou quoi
quand même les trous
et aussi dans le cavalier bah voilà bah
on est des gens je crois en fait avec
des génies
du jeu d'échec qu'on trouve tous les
coups
refusé F5 F4 c'est normal qu'avait
raison que je suis pas encore sûr de ce
qu'ils veulent faire parce que peut-être
que des fois j'ai même pu G5 mais bon je
suis moins fan parce que c'est vrai que
la diagonale noire est un peu plus
ouverte
ah oui non mais en fait je trouve en
plus je vois en pratique c'est tellement
plus simple pour le noir
il est facile pourquoi tu fais les en 4K
toi tu fais quel est le 5 mais ton plan
est là
j'aime bien ton rêve
ça permet de bouger la dame aussi hein
un truc concret vite fait mais faut
prendre les trois FG dame c'est 7 ou
Dame des 6 à la place de toi mais je
sais pas enfin c'est juste pour
l'attaquer le truc et dur à défendre
mais peut-être d'un de ces 7 pour pas
laisser sa tête
et sur ça
un truc comme ça mais bon peut-être à
enfin peut-être c'est rien mais
c'est lui que je me questionnais tu vois
parce que
après en même temps tu t'enlèves 4 et
puis
c'est tout
c'est souple parce que ça dépend à 7 ça
c'est important
H5 pour échanger les pièces et ben là
j'ai un très joli coup c'est fou projet
3 on va enlever le défenseur de la dame
tout en défendant la dame et maintenant
s'il prend le fou bah je prends sa dame
gratuit et s'il prend ma dame je prends
avec le flou donc je te mange un
cavalier gratos
donc un joli coup qui attaque et qui
défend ouais donc dommage 4 déjà il y a
pas de
dans ma chambre c'est pas mal ça a l'air
fort
G3
plus tard
sur le long terme il faudra récupérer la
case des quatre pour la dame
mais bon c'est quand même menace ça ça
foutrant
et encore des choses à faire et
franchement écoute alors donc Fabi
il a vraiment un fait une très bonne
partie de ce que là
pendule chose qui qui faisait pas et
quelques années Fabi on l'a dit hier
encore ça fait quelques années qui
commencent à être vraiment très bon en
rapide des Blitz aussi même sur Internet
et au tout début des parties sur
internet il était un peu la ramasse par
rapport aux autres aujourd'hui
par exemple les speed
chessine
quoi
un des derniers speech il avait battu
Maxime donc déjà c'était autre chose
[Musique]
maintenant en fait
l'échec sont de plus en plus populaires
en tout cas sur sur Internet c'est il a
compris que c'était un petit peu
peut-être le futur maintenant des échecs
avec 45 qui a moitié prix sa retraite
qui veut jouer que sur Internet aussi
non mais du coup justement il y a
peut-être un truc à faire pour regagner
le titre de champion du monde ouais
boucher par la présence de Magnus de ce
point de vue là c'est vrai que
maintenant que le loup n'est plus là
mais en fait je sais pas enfin pour
toute cette génération qui était
matraquée par Carlsen depuis 10 ans
tu te dis pourquoi pas en plus si tu es
pas si loin Ligue des champions du monde
c'était qualifié il a joué le match il a
fait 6 6 quoi
justement j'ai l'impression que j'aime
bien que morale et que depuis il a quand
même il jouait moins bien quoi
tu accuses le coup et peut-être tu te
dis bon j'ai fait tous les efforts en
fait j'ai mal battre parce qu'en lente
malgré tout je peux pas et en fait en
rapide il est trop fort pour moi et donc
pourquoi je
enfin pourquoi faire quoi mais là bon il
est plus là donc
je sais pas ça donne envie de aller on
redonne un petit coup de collier et qui
sait quoi
ouais c'est ça
faisait partie en 2005 quoi
finalement tu vois c'était topaloffre le
gars qui a mis le coup de colis
alors que
bon
c'était plus fort quoi
et ouais
tu te dis ah peut-être il y a un truc à
faire à ce moment là ça c'est ma chance
et que ok il faut essayer
ouais et
non mais c'est vrai que ça ça peut en
motiver pas mal de gens qui avaient plus
ou moins entre guillemets pas jeter
l'éponge mais tu vois
cette chance tu essaiera mais tu crois
moyen quoi donc peut-être un moment
c'est de faire trop d'efforts je me suis
déjà un peu entraîné aujourd'hui faire
autre chose ça va en fait tu as le droit
en fait mais quand un objectif aussi
élevé bah là tu peux peut-être te redire
allez vas-y je me fais mes 8 heures par
jour
j'avais pensé à Tours
5 c'est d'échanger les fous et de garder
un peu la case case F4
je crois que j'arrivais pas à attendre
j'ai l'impression que il y a quelqu'un
[Musique]
mais ça a l'air tu vois tu dis bon
peut-être
[Musique]
mais je sais pas
tout refait
OK
et puis un moment il va il va te faire
F4 ou foutrangez trois gagnez un pion et
en plus menacer un défend G3
je suis pas mécontent
voir qu'en fait avec les Noirs ça se
passe bien parce que comme je comprenais
rien à Fuger 5 fois des deux ça me
renforce dans mes
[Musique]
F4 là je pense qu'on a toutes les pièces
sur les meilleures cases
le problème c'est quoi là je voulais
faire F4 mais qu'elle va aller prendre
un 4 donc en fait
donc maintenant que bah ok là je peux
plus attendre plus et je dois faire 4
c'est la partie
on peut pas améliorer plus enfin je
dirais un moment
non pourquoi tu joues quoi
en puissance
bon enfin
au passage pas tellement comment il
compte défendre
F4 est obligatoire ouais mais juste en
reprendre on va faire autrement
F4
et justement faire autrement le coup
d'après quoi
je sais pas trop comment
on se dévoile
[Musique]
c'est une horreur on est d'accord
sachant déjà
enfin ça c'est l'option
c'est déjà ça
et j'ai pas le temps de manger
non mais c'est horrible c'est
complètement horrible après il a
toujours de la ressource donc il va nous
trouver un truc il est mal au temps
quand même il a 50 secondes contre 3
minutes 30 et une poubelle
non bah non on peut dire bon c'est la
première partie du match peut-être que
peut-être qu'il est pas chaud il tente
d'un H5 maintenant bah il a pas trouvé
mieux et donc on est dit f-3 après si ça
se trouve il y a encore mieux mais bon
[Musique]
en fait
c'est simple en fait
c'est déjà un pion
ça ouvre la colonel on a les tours
doublés dessus on a J6 bon
je peux ramener une pièce
c'est juste horrible
[Musique]
ok il est malin il trouve des coups mais
bon ça va pas il veut peut-être que ça
prenne un F3 faire tourger deux faire
pousser trois et tu vas se réactiver et
comme ça
je fais rien mais peut-être que lui il
fait quoi j'en sais rien
[Musique]
après tu peux me manger depuis un direct
ça c'est aussi un pion 92
[Musique]
je crois qu'il est en juillet donc il a
même pas encore 31 ça je sais pas ça
date enfin cet anniversaire je connais
c'est quand ta date à toi le 3
août peut-être
[Musique]
exactement la date parce que là on en
parle trop pour pas de
grosses
à Miami
je crois que il est bon États-Unis mais
il a de la famille qui était italienne
alors
c'est la mère qui d'ailleurs
biographie
parce qu'il a joué son drapeau de
l'Italie pendant longtemps ça fait pas
longtemps ça fait peut-être aller entre
5 et 10 ans qu'il est qu'il est
américain quoi
aux échecs
parce qu'il a joué pour l'Italie pendant
longtemps pour moi
et puis c'est bien enfin il y a pas de
souci mais tu peux pas changer comme tu
changes de club quoi non mais en fait
pour moi c'est quand tu habitais dans le
pays toute ta vie c'est pas
je le vois pas comme quelque chose de
dire
pas bien
il se fait natureliser et qu'il n'a rien
à voir il est vraiment américain
aussi dans le foot
où tu as des joueurs qui sont
binationaux ou quoi et en fait si tu
choisis une sélection donc tu choisis
bien avant de la choisir tu peux plus
jouer dans une autre c'est fini bon
après quand on regarde enfin lui sa
naissance c'est italien quoi enfin en
fait voilà bah il fait comme il veut en
fait
on te sélectionne un équipe nationale tu
as le droit de dire bah non j'attends
comme sélectionne dans l'autre
d'ailleurs et souvent on se cache
justement avec l'équipe de France au
foot ou les mecs ils sont un peu sueurs
parce qu'ils ira bien joué par l'équipe
de France mais ils savent c'est hyper
dur parce que c'est hyper fort au foot
la France et que c'est dense et ils se
disent ouais peut-être déjà plus de
chance avec mon autre pays mais bon en
même temps ça me fait moins rêver
tu vois tu as quatre conscience mais
c'est pas juste bon bah je vais à la
carte dans l'un dans l'autre comme je
veux quoi
et aux échecs qui a trop ça donc là
c'est pas pour ça c'est pas spécialement
Fabiano et puis d'ailleurs lui comme je
dis c'est un des cas d'ailleurs les plus
les plus normaux dans le truc mais il y
a tellement de joueurs qui qui tout d'un
coup pris une nationalité de pas
pourquoi et puis ils vont jouer pour un
pays bon il parle même pas la langue
bon c'est spécial quoi
à moitié comment tu comment tu non mais
ce que je veux dire c'est quand même tu
vas que prendre des paires de Calais je
vois encore une super finale mais
vraiment juste ça et puis
on espérait plus qu'un pion quand même
il avait une pièce
je crois que quand il y a peu de temps
il suit un peu enfin il nous a fait le
courant de Julie hier et là peut-être il
va pas la gagner enfin
parce que franchement
mais bon c'est dramatique s'il gagne pas
en fait genre pour le match avec une
pièce de plus
il gagne pas ça il va vraiment
tu gagnes un peu ton dessus il prend et
on mange de l'autre finalement
le roi est passé
c'est ouf
mais ouais c'est la force
mais là je trouve que c'est incroyable
parce que c'est
je trouve que c'était vraiment
pas c'est la faute de cabane il a
entendu la question en fait
[Musique]
tu as qu'un contre-jupe qui ont dépassé
de toute façon peut-être que lui a
surveiller il se fait avoir par ce truc
mais du coup
ça change pas mal de match en fait là la
famille moi j'étais sûr qu'il allait
gagner que j'ai fait une démonstration
pour le battre on sait que c'est
difficile quoi
changer les tours
attention
où il a rendu la pièce je pensais au
moins qu'il pouvait la rendre peut-être
avoir une Belgique
des fois
mais
[Musique]
et qu'est-ce qu'il a fait du coup
si tu as vraiment besoin
en fait
non mais c'est pas une facilement
[Musique]
on sait que du coup fais voir que F4 D6
c'était déjà trop tard aussi il pouvait
pas comme faire un truc alors
apparemment la présentation c'était
ouais
peut-être tourner
il y a eu ça
quand tu as vu
c'est le roi blanc qui vient s'activer
il te il te fait mal quoi et là tu peux
plus bouger quoi
mais en fait tu vois dans cette position
même si même si ça devient
dur il y a quand même une part de une
part de
réussite qui soit
mais là je peux y croire que ça gagne
pas
je vais lui un truc c'est pas mal dans
le livre de marine je crois sur Lord for
the legend je pense
qui te dit que dans les finales de Tours
il faut deux avantages pour gagner
il fait ça un peu comme un score de foot
n'importe quel sport là en fait le
jardin parce que tu as un pion de plus
mais en fait il faudrait et le pion de
plus et autre chose genre la tour active
le roi actif ou je sais pas quoi et en
fait les blancs ils ont le droit actifs
et Machin donc en fait tu mets que 1-0
au mieux avec les Noirs quoi et
normalement ça suffit pas pour gagner ok
général comme d'hab hein
ou même les 00 tu gagnes mais
que ça peut permettre de juger de loin
c'était pas trop sûr tu comptes un peu
comme ça et là en fait ce roi blanc qui
fait F5 c'est quand même un truc hyper
important on a la même position avec le
roi blanc F2 je pense ça vient
facilement qu'en fait
on pourra activer le droit facilement
pour famille on était
parti méritait imméritait de gagner
celle-là mais c'est fou parce que Abdou
il est quand même réussi à créer le
problème pratique chiant avec son roi
qui monte en fait je pense qu'il a vu
qu'il fasse cavalier il s'est dit vas-y
prends-le je monte plus ou moins fermé
je suis sûr que c'est pas du enfin c'est
incroyable
des parties comme ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour pour la deuxième
partie j'espère que vous avez apprécié
ces pubs autant que nous
on est resté la regarder franchement
tellement ça nous plaisait
[Rires]
t'abruti avec les quatre pubs qu'on a
et alors
je pense que c'est pas une Espagnole
parce qu'on a pas encore joué
avec un des 600
et donc il est parti en A4 et pas en F1
c'est l'autre l'autre
différence tu vois en fait soit avec
avec fue et fin et mais généralement
quand je pouvais pas avec ces quatre en
fait
tu peux faire ce truc aussi tu peux
aussi faire sa 3D
OK et en mode donc ouais la pression qui
ressemble aux Espagnols
franchement c'est un truc qui existe sur
une vente que j'ai sur la Sicilienne en
fait il y a un Tourcoing
c'est la même position dans le dans une
société avec un
fou en B7 et mon planque de tranchées
mais j'ai un truc un peu similaire
et un truc comme ça avec
le fou en baissé ça a de la gueule
et je sais plus comment c'est du coup
faut retarder des quatre
oui alors ton truc ou non ça va en fait
dans mon truc tu
[Musique]
as
en fait après
alors je sais plus comment
des questions peut-être des trois
cavaler des deux et le plan et après on
temporise pour jeter des cartes quoi
un livre sur les pubs en vrai en vrai on
se fait un livre de pub c'est pas mal
mais en fait ce sera un très bon livre
mais
c'est un peu comme le Culture pub mais
en mode livre ou tu racontes plus
histoire des pubs les machins
comment ouais je trouve ça intéressant
comment ça a été des anecdotes sur les
tournages
ouais ok bon problème c'est que j'ai
aucune compétence mais c'est intéressant
pour l'instant je suis un peu dans les
livres d'échecs donc je vais déjà
bien tout faire dessus mais après dans
un deuxième temps ma carrière d'écrivain
sera lancée ok je garde
en tout cas moi je les garde tu sais que
j'ai tous les toutes les pubs là depuis
des années que je commence à commenter
les événements c'est comme j'ai tout sur
l'ordinateur juste tu m'appelles
on pourrait se faire des soirées en fait
je te fais un petit film en plus on a on
a humé sur le chat nous fait un il nous
fait un petit un petit récap avec toutes
les pubs qu'on a pu faire depuis le
début pas mal
c'est ma ticket
attendre que les Blancs je vois je joue
des 4 pour rejoindre fou G4 l'idée de
taper sur cavalier 3 par exemple on
pourrait menacer un jour j'ai trois et
sort d'un point F3 à 4 et donc forcément
mais juste cette position si jamais par
exemple jouer un coup comme comme fou
prend fin B3 et ben juste en fait cette
position et bien il faut voir que elle
peut ne pas être très grave pour le
blanc c'est pas parce que voilà c'est
pas parce que j'ai ouvert mon roi que
mon roi il a poil alors par rapport à
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que là la
colonne g bon bah pas taper sur le plan
G7 même sur le site c'est quand même
relativement solide mais j'ai la paire
de fou j'ai le centre ils m'ont en fait
il est assez bien défendu quoi je fous
trois dames des deux gars etc 300 quand
même pour cacher puis écoute j'ai
l'intéresse pas quoi et avec tes pièces
qu'est-ce que tu fais juste tu fais ça
cool
on ramène le front F1 oui tu peux
trouver
il reviendra à la maison bien mais des
fois auprès de moi c'est pas si grave et
des fois ça peut même être un avantage
et plein de gens des fois on va se
laisser
volontairement mangeant un froid pour
gagner un avantage qui peut être dû au
centre d'activité à l'espace par défaut
à plein de choses
et bon du coup là dans la partie il y a
pas du tout eu ça il y a eu 3
un petit peu mieux quoi tu as un beau
centre
salut François
e
j'ai pas de stock quoi non non je vais
me l'acheter mais sinon enfin moi ça
serait volontiers en fait j'adore un
méga stock mais c'est vrai que tu
pourrais avoir un petit stock et puis
les dédicacés les vendre tu vois comme
tu avais tu avais fait le le livre sur
la cage
moi je t'en avais acheté un pour
m'offrir un anniversaire quand tu viens
Alexis Alexis qui est fan de Kalash et
donc dédicacer à l'époque
et donc voilà donc c'est sympa aussi
dédicacer
tu vas un tournoi bah tiens bouffe
et puis ça va quoi
je pourrais me constituer mon stock tout
seul en fait mais bon
oui oui bon après ça
bon allez c'est ouais mais c'est vrai
que bon c'est toujours sympa en plus
quand tu connais l'auteur et que tu vois
de pouvoir
dédicacer et cetera discuter avec toi
bon après même si je dis casse rien vous
pouvez venir discuter avec moi il y a
pas de souci
ça va tu es assez accessible ça on le
sait et puis c'est cool aussi d'avoir
des gens et des pouvoirs savants tu les
stages aussi d'ailleurs tu as bientôt à
Barcelone je crois qu'il m'avait dit
neuf au 13 août 9 au 13 août à Barcelone
tu as du monde encore tu as la place ou
c'est un petit peu
donc il doit rester
bon de toute façon c'est pas la place
près mais je veux dire peut-être enfin
déjà s'arrêter là ça irait bien mais
cinq places on va dire 5 places donc
stage à Barcelone un stage d'échec avec
Amazon avec Sébastien Mazet que je pense
que tout le monde connaît sur le
capitaine
avec son beau costumes et donc là je
sais pas si il aura
tout le temps en fait
et donc voilà ça j'avais Barcelone du 9
au 13 août donc n'hésitez pas à réserver
vos places
et
je suis sympa
j'aime bien tous dans tous leurs
charmes mais un stage en fait sur
plusieurs joueurs comme ça puis tu as
bien le temps de créer un groupe de
connaître les gens de passer du temps
quand tu es sur un week-end c'est plus
intensif quoi donc c'est bien aussi
c'est différent mais moi le fromage
préféré c'est des stages longs
avec qui tu es aussi il y a un côté
échec bien entendu les gens viennent
pour progresser pour apprendre des
choses etc mais les gens viennent aussi
pour te connaître pour pour juste en
fait passer une semaine sympa à faire
des échecs avec des gens sympas
et donc vous allez voir cela avec une
équipe sympa des des bons des formateurs
que tout le monde sait que vous êtes
pédagogue et très qualifié pour tout ça
et en plus en plus vous vous amusez donc
c'est vraiment sympa en tout cas
bon c'était dans le coin tu peux passer
bah ouais moi je suis pas loin en guest
tu m'as dit
à peu près je suis inscrit à un tournoi
déjà qui est du 5 au 11 et c'est sur
un tournoi s'inscrit mais
[Musique]
peu la flemme
après si tu as un vol retour des
Canaries qui peut encore pris tu te tais
à Barcelone le 12 c'est la dernière
soirée
non c'est ah c'est au 13 pardon
mais bon en fait le tournoi
en fait quand j'avais dit que je voulais
le faire je savais pas que j'allais
autant jouer enfin jouer et j'ai pas
envie de faire trop de tournoi ça va me
en fait avant quand j'étais plus jeune
je faisais
[Musique]
je faisais tous les semaines un tournoi
une semaine un tournoi et maintenant bah
je suis un peu plus vieux quoi enfin en
fait c'est quand tu fais des chèques
toute la journée et voilà
on est pareil
j'ai sentiments aussi et j'ai plus envie
enfin je veux un tournoi
c'est à dire que j'ai deux mois à dire
juillet août il y a plein de tournois on
fait un enjeuillet et en août je suis
content
donc là je vais jouer quoi je vais jouer
bon je vais jouer un tournoi là en juin
c'est de passer émis enfin là
c'est pas encore réglé il manque un
point tu sais
une ronde va suffire
[Musique]
que voilà mais donc je vais faire ça en
juin fin juin et et après en juillet je
joue à voile
avec des amis et après
[Musique]
en août voilà ils étaient une arête je
t'avais dit donc ça fait quand même
ça fait bon le 3 juin là c'est pour
passer émis je le compte pas comme un
tournoi vraiment
sérieux où je pars tu vois genre c'est à
la maison quoi enfin c'est pas loin de
chez moi
pas sûr toujours non plus on va tourner
avec Barbie
puissions
[Musique]
qui finalement viennent pas donc
maintenant il est tout seul
en fait c'est de base j'avais envie de
jouer alors je suis tout seul ça va être
pire presque t'as des amis sur place ou
quoi ce réfléchit
pas envie ça me saoule
[Musique]
donc bon j'avais déjà dit que je dirais
j'aime pas dire non quand je passe pas
comique mais bon
désengager si j'étais pas inscrit alors
là ce serait non et je te dirai oui
Barcelone
là j'ai quand même je suis inscrit puis
en plus après il y a un rapide derrière
en fait je finis 13 tu vois
ça fait 11 Lopez mais bon
presque quand même pas mal de canari
aussi
non oui mais bon j'ai vécu un an en fait
non tu connais maintenant
ça me fait plus rien d'y aller enfin
avant quand je partais là-bas c'était
l'expédition c'était content j'allais à
la plage tous les jours
maintenant tout lui je te dis bah non je
dois bon classique
tu connais
[Musique]
bon voilà bon un petit peu un petit peu
nos
histoires
à Barcelone pas mal et d'ailleurs
sentent séquencer
du 22 au 30 enfin j'essaye des dates
mais parce qu'il y a un gros gros
tournoi qui se joue
700 joueurs chaque année 50 grands
mètres enfin c'est un bel open c'est un
très bel open c'est un gros truc et
c'est vrai que couplet enfin le stage et
après enchaîné avec avec Le Pen mais bon
tu peux pas rester trop longtemps à
Barcelone
ça va faire vraiment une une semaine de
de pause probablement donc c'est dur de
faire les deux après de toute façon en
Espagne ils font ce qu'ils appellent le
circuit catalan donc il y a plein de
tournois tout le temps ouais donc en
fait c'est possible probablement de
meubler être des choses à faire ou de se
faire des vacances y aller ou bon de
toute façon
tu fais une semaine de stage une semaine
de pause trois semaines à Barcelone
qu'en fait la plupart des gens qui vont
venir au stage qui sont pas pro quoi
oui donc déjà il pose des vacances
et puis là
[Musique]
B4
j'aime bien cavaler des quatre OK
moi l'option est attaqué il est plus
ouais surprise qu'elle va les prendre
qui chasse le cavalier et gagnerait
ignobles qui gagne cavaliers
donc puis en plus ça me donne aussi des
cases en C6
et si le fou s'en va ben je commence à
avoir aussi le tour c'est un donc
peut-être B3 d'abord je sais pas
une Cavada
peut-être B3 je sais pas si c'est
possible mais si je peux faire ça et ça
en fait j'ai gagné j'ai gagné une
cavalier
mais bon il y a une paire de fou quand
même chez les Blancs et potentiellement
ça peut faire ça peut faire mal à
on va voir si on sort encore parce que
ça avait l'air d'aller très bien sa
partie sa position et puis
je prends un peu le bouillon là
mais est-ce que c'est possible de le ça
ça
est-ce que c'est pas un décisif qui peut
être un peu relou
se trouver des idées tu sais à base de
ça ça
moi j'aime bien les blancs parce que tu
as des problèmes de 8e rangée là
un petit peu la pause j'arrive pas à
attaquer en fait
moi franchement même si on m'a pas enfin
cette paire de fou des pions à droite à
gauche x 2 qui peut attaquer FC ça a
l'air chiant pour les Noirs juste
mais bon
on a vu là-bas
avec nous ça suffit pas non ok bon on
voit quand même que au niveau du jeu
d'échec des parties Caravana il est
quand même plutôt pas mal
tu vois ça partie bon il a fait une
masterclass la deuxième ben ça se passe
pas mal du tout non plus et dans la
qualité des parties il est pas du tout à
plaindre en tout cas
pas du tout à plaindre ici car voilà
même si il a quand même raté un petit
Joker particulièrement
t'imagines s'il avait gagné la partie
d'avant
ciao quoi enfin tu vois donc ça change
quand même pas mal
[Musique]
la fiche de l'ami un peu du match tout
ça mais bon ok il faut il faut se battre
et
cette partie elle est quand même pas mal
donc là il vient de dépasser à des
autographes au temps et qu'elle est huit
peut être un coup j'ai envie de dire
peut-être sérieux même si tu as pas
envie de le faire qu'elle avait 8 mais
il faut bien se défendre parce que là la
prise elle a l'air trop dur
il y a trop de problèmes CC6 aussi qui
est possible
d'ailleurs si tu bouges de cavalier même
si tu avais une case
B3 même si en fait
c'est juste c'est juste perdu il a fait
le 5
[Rires]
ans alors attends ça fait depuis 1h
qu'on regarde ça et on disait que
c'était l'air pas mal pour les blancs
je sais pas trop penser
cavalier prend donc menace G5 OK et s'il
vous s'en va peut-être faire ça en fait
[Musique]
c'est pas possible
on va on va essayer de pas le faire mais
après du coup c'est pour ça il faut
peut-être apprendre C6 mais
je sais pas non mais oui donc cette
ligne du coup kamel est prof alors faut
quand même pas imaginé mais je ne
t'arrête à foot B5 perso ouais mais pas
bête parce que moi ça maintient la
teurant C8 il y a plus de fous prends
ces deux portes de la 8e rangée ça évite
j'ai 5 enfin ça évite on peut le faire
son envie mais il y a plus aucun sens à
le faire maintenant
donc ok je comprends l'idée
quand même s'accrocher côté Abdou encore
une fois
après ça reste quand même toujours j'ai
envie de dire une menace il y a une
fourchette là
je coupe quand même la
communication entre ces deux pièces même
si le Fou est là encore
[Musique]
et ben il a encore une fois trouvé le
coup qui est un peu chiant pratique
[Musique]
son gros point fort
il va rien donner
il va se battre sur toutes les balles
il va essayer vraiment de de enfin il a
une étude de tueur en fait
parce que il t'accroche tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps c'est Nadal
en fait c'est le Nadal des échecs
surtout des points il va de là et ils
dift
[Rires]
tu crois qu'il est une souris normale en
fait non il a la petite boule pour
te mettre le rebond quoi donc
j'essaye moi si tu vois j'ai une souris
comme ça avec la petite truc qui se
tourne c'est quoi ça
c'est moi rapide mais c'est ma souris en
fait j'ai pas de sous j'ai rien c'est un
truc qui tient debout et ça ça tourne
donc c'est pas obligé ma souris à droite
à gauche devant derrière quoi je peux
lister avec ma story
standard quoi attends je peux vous la
montrer ouais mais en fait j'avais pris
ça pour soigner une tendinite ok j'ai
une tendinite tu radis mais en fait à
force d'être toujours comme ça
je sais pas toute la journée en fait on
m'avait dit ah essaie de prendre
ergonomique et sur le côté et tu bouges
comme ça en fait tu es tranquille tu as
ta main je suis en position normale
et donc bon bah au début j'avais pas
trop à bouger ce truc c'était hyper
chiant mais non bon à force je commence
à avoir l'habitude quoi
ok
d'ailleurs même
au cas où j'ai une soirée normale si je
dois accélérer quoi un moment je change
quoi ouais ouais c'est un match de
partage je sais que tu dis attends une
seconde chance de raquette pas
mais ça va aller plus vite
[Musique]
donc bah écoute
il y a trop de choses à attaquer
c'est chaud là
qui réfléchit il ne reste plus que deux
minutes à la pendule
et
quelque chose trop trop
[Musique]
et puis même si on prend ce qu'il y a
trois jours de toute façon tu as B prend
à trois il est juste à deux caisses de
dames il est chiant quand ce pion c'est
un peu le pion d de la partie d'avant
il est à l'aise exception passé
alors j'ai vu j'ai vu le coup qui avait
l'air de d'être gagnant pour les blancs
et j'ai pas compris encore
[Rires]
[Musique]
direct ça marche pas j'envoie quelqu'un
chez toi regarde partout
il y a une caméra qui traîne
et là dépend
ordinateur enfin c'est beaucoup trop dur
à imaginer
beaucoup trop dur et en plus sur X à
deux bah pas de B3 qui peut regarder
encore
c'est complètement coupé non non non
c'est trop fort donc tour de 4K va les
prendre là tu penses qu'il veut faire
comprendre à 4 mais ils ont joué qui
prend bien
le 7 donc là il me laisse tour des 8
échecs et quasiment mats qui bloque
alors surtout on l'a eau il y a juste
rouge en fait
exactement c'est le X 4 fais son boulot
de défendre ouais en plus quasiment les
tableaux de maths je bouge ma tour en
fait et juste je te montre ça ça
n'est pas si loin que ça de trouver non
mais c'est chaud c'est une position très
chaude en fait c'est extraordinaire il
comprend B4 ok donc il a une pièce de 2
mois 32 pions et il y a un qui est bien
complètement idiot comme l'autre de la
partie d'avant enfin c'est des cavaliers
à l'opposé de l'échiquier et c'est chaud
c'est très chaud c'est très chaud non
non mais moi je préfère toujours les
blancs hein on peut se gagner côté blanc
parce que ça m'a l'air tellement dur en
pratique il faut toujours surveiller ça
et puis j'ai l'autre point qui peut
passer à côté en même temps bon même si
le pion B2 je vais pas trop envie de
bouger pour l'instant parce que c'est
que dès que je le bouge ben hop coucou
je ressors quoi là
ça devrait valoir quelque chose quand
même qui avait dit qu'il va prendre la
place d'un cavalier adverse dans son sur
sa caisse de départ tu vois c'est un peu
comme toujours petit chevaux et tu
arrives dans le camp adverse parce que
normalement c'est bien quoi
ça arrive jamais quoi donc là quand même
non c'est une diagonale en Pégase quoi
et finalement il a des ailes ici pour
fermer en B1 il saute là il vient en F6
il vient soutenir l'autre
et voilà voici pour les fous parce que
quand tu passes avec trois dans la
rangée tu te transforme en fait pâtes à
la promotion c'est la promotion qui fait
si on va quelque chose sur le 3e
mais bon pourquoi
parce qu'en fait
c'est un fouet
oui et non pourquoi
[Musique]
je crois que c'est je crois que je crois
que ça fait ça fait tour mais d'une case
il me semble je suis pas sûr
du coup bah sur fou là je préfère
plein de choses excusez-moi
son tour
je crois le plus durer passé le problème
c'est pour gagner quasiment mais
ok partie très compliqué en fait
[Musique]
c'est c'est dingue quoi parce que
franchement
après faut H6
ça avait l'air tellement dur enfin
l'écoute les voyais et
[Musique]
tous les coups
ok donc là il a une pièce de plus il y a
deux pions pour la pièce mais il y a
plus beaucoup de pions et plus enfin moi
il y a un pion plus
l'essence de faire nul avec les Blancs
quand même donc là je sens qu'il me
donne le pion qui est en prise 2 fois
mais attention sur une prise
je peux que tu perdes une pièce
et de l'autre côté c'est un peu la même
je crois les fourchettes
ça reste compliqué je sais pas si il y a
moyen de
mais des pièces noires
F4 donc là c'est une position beaucoup
trop compliqué les gens ont pas de 20
secondes
[Musique]
ou quoi bref 4 ça va attaque aussi que
je peux mater là je suis à deux couteau
même qu'elle c'est fini
[Musique]
alors là il faut regarder les
forteresses
en fait c'est une échanges tes tours
fous ensemble mais il y a deux cavaliers
pour les Noirs
contre un roi et un pion ça peut gagner
ça dépend et si votre pion est hyper
avancé ça va être nul parce que le
cavalier va être bloquer le pion pour
passer marrant on a fait une vidéo on
parlait de ça sur Blitz stream il y a
trois quatre jours parce qu'il y a eu la
finale Carlson mvl
on Pologne au bled et en fait Magnus
avait deux caler contre un pion ok mais
l'option était déjà H4 et ouais c'est un
peu trop bon
mais il se trouve qu'avant l'ordi donne
un gain en 46 coups
mais ils avaient déjà joué trop de coup
avant donc de toute façon il y aurait la
règle des 50 mais
membre au final j'ai jamais étudié quoi
enfin tu dois jamais tu dis oui bon puis
même si je l'ai je saurai plus
ouais après tu connais pas tu connais
pas les principes donc tu seras de je
comprends mais
de démarcation avec
pour savoir si c'est gagnant pas gagnant
et je suis même pas trop sûr de la ligne
en fait
voilà un peu je dirais
à 5
[Musique]
à 5b4 c'est
c'est 4
ça c'est des trois ou des quatre des
trois E3 et symétrique quoi
gagner mais bon à vérifier
mais c'est sûr que si j'ai les blancs et
que j'ai un plan H2 avec un cavalier
noir qui va me bloquer en A3
et que j'en ai cavalier là je vais
gagner
le principe c'est de bloquer le cavalier
de bloquer le plan cavalier et avec le
roi lot de cavalue c'est de ramener le
roi un petit peu dans un coin et une
fois que c'est fait je travaille mon
cavalier j'ai raté quoi et pendant le
temps là le pion va avancer
l'idée c'est de mater avant que le pion
fasse d'âme ou alors
parce que deux cavaliers c'est nul en
fait et tu sais que moi j'ai une partie
à Barcelone d'ailleurs il y a maintenant
de nombreuses années j'avais joué un
grand maître cubain et j'avais torpion
[Musique]
une case de la dame mais bon il allait
manger quand il voulait mais bon enfin
c'est nul quoi et je comprends je
propose de nul à refuser là il a essayé
de tourner bon bah ouais après il a
finalement il m'a laissé faire dame j'ai
mangé j'ai mangé enfin il m'a mangé la
dame ah bah là
je me souviens je me suis levé
et je savais que ça gagne pas quoi mais
je te promets il arrive avec ses
cavaliers ça fait trop peur
faut vraiment faire exprès pour faire je
me souviens j'avais même demandé il y
avait Romu qui était là ok
j'avais 2300
que les échecs ça te fait psychoter quoi
des trucs que tu sais depuis que tu as 3
ans bon bah victoire d'abdos incroyable
donc
franchement encore une fois une partie
enfin une défense monstrueuse quand tu
vois la partie après après faut acheter
ça j'ai envie de dire dès qu'il arrive à
chaque fois acheter ça avec les Blancs
tu as l'impression que c'est trop trop
dur en fait
E5
bon là apparemment il y a eu il y avait
un coup il faut prendre
en fait c'est dur de enfin de pas perdre
ça comme Caravana je sais pas qui arrive
en fait oui non mais c'est
vraiment vraiment bien quoi
dans la partie le seul coup qui permet
de gagner c'est fou à deux quoi
et on a vu la suite on a vu la suite non
S4 W c'est c'est fou cavalier c'est
la lune qui gagne c'est c'est
hallucinant mais même en partie
ça gagne vite fait quoi enfin de toute
façon ça dépend
si tu joues encore les meilleurs coups
je sais pas moi
en fait là il y a plus aucun coup
logique mais de toute façon la position
est trop bizarre pour être logique
on sait pas trop
il prend ce truc finalement
c'est une ligne d'ordi qui est
absolument introuvable quoi enfin même
tu l'aimes ça
x 2 tu peux le regarder en entier
mais bon tu dis oui moi je perds une
tour et puis je fais un échec qui cache
son roi et je pense que ça
tu peux voir la ligne mais de là à te
dire que c'est hyper
oui non c'est intéressant mais bon quand
même c'est une tour de moi bon mais
arrive à jouer c'est autre chose
et donc là il a joué le deuxième
meilleur pool d'ordi quoi
et cette position elle est très
difficile et en pratique c'est chaud tu
as une pièce de moi tu as quand même
deux pions mais tu as une case de la
dame tu as du jeu parce qu'avec qui au
fraise en bien
mais bon ben
Fabiano il a plus de temps à la pendule
et comme il peut mais bon encore une
fois enfin il trouve des des trucs quand
même j'ai 5 c'est pas
c'est le seul coup qui fait nuit
encore mais bon je comprends que tu as
envie de te râler 6 donc il faut réagir
et même juste F4 moi j'ai 6 c'est quoi
la pointe en fait
quand j'ai 5 ah ok compris voilà
en fait parce que tout à l'heure la
ligne qui prend le 5 quoi et ben oui ben
j'ai pas rêve de quoi
ça
attaque j'ai 5 plein de fois et surtout
j'aimerais F2 donc tu as pas le temps de
venir manger mes pièces parce que tu as
un tour en prise et juste
complètement au bord ah oui non mais
il y a aucune pièce qui est bien placé
on dirait que c'est un ils ont mis des
pièces comme ça au hasard et paf ça a
fait ça
juste F3 c'est pas un coup pour voir ah
non mais là j'aurai décidé du coup il me
laisse pas
mais oui
ok la différence entre 4
FK 3G 6 je prends 5
après F4 ok car on a il le trouve c'est
là du temps quand même 4 je pense parce
que c'est pareil
la production c'est un bordel son nom
[Musique]
oui mais si ça avait enfin si il avait
un peu de temps la pendule je pense
qu'il est capable de trouver F4 mais bon
c'est incroyable que Abdou il finisse
par gagner la partie en fait il a trouvé
il a trouvé une défense incroyable et
derrière bah il en vient c'est même lui
à ta pression quoi là pour l'instant
dans ce match je vais mettre le score
mettre à l'envers ou ça non parce que je
préfère les Hauts-de-Seine donc j'ai un
échiquier
noir donc pas trop si on doit retrouver
des X ou des idées justement j'ai gardé
j'ai gardé que les scènes qui marchait
donc oui là Abdou il mène un point et
demi à 0 et demi dans ce dans ce match
alors qu'il aurait pu être mis de zéro
quoi
et ça c'est incroyable il a gagné une
partie et fait une nulle alors qu'il
était favori pour perdre les deux
parties d'affilée quoi et ça je trouve
qu'encore une fois
il est il est vraiment là quoi enfin
c'est juste hallucinant comment comment
il joue quoi ça bouge pas ça
mais en fait tu vois c'est oui c'est
il se bat mais c'est c'est ouf comment
il se bat et puis
il a une attitude qui est qui est
incroyable
ok ok bon écoutez ben il reste il reste
plus qu'un peut-être une partie
peut-être de
il reste deux parties donc
carbonade doit plus perdre il risque de
partir si karenaille
il faut qu'il fasse un et demi minimum
après donc mission compliquée pas
impossible mais mission pas facile
facile ouais donc là c'est Abdou quand
elle est blanc en plus c'est Abdou gagne
c'est terminé et puis et puis et puis il
aura gagné 7 on va dire ce tournoi cet
événement un cheeseccap cheesekit Cup
pardon et en cas de nul encore une
partie minimum mais il faut vraiment
karena arrive à recoller au score et il
reste deux parties à faire seulement le
format c'est 15 + 3 la cadence vous avez
quatre parties et en cas de en cas
d'égalité et ben il va y avoir tout
simplement
tout simplement une partie Armageddon
pour départager
donc voilà
voilà bon allez il faut que je vous
montre les petites pubs là et puis on
revient dans un instant
trois minutes dès que ça dès que ça
lance quoi à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non nous sommes de retour
avec pas bien qui est là et on a la
partie
qui vient de commencer à l'instant
donc c'est une partie ici alors on va
regarder un petit peu le début
pour avoir cette position
donc
c'est assez standard le fou qui allait
manger en C3
je ne connais pas du tout
moi pas trop non plus mais
il s'est laissé manger en M6 pour
récupérer la part de fou et les cases
noires
donc au prix du rock tout à l'heure on
parle on vous parle de ce roi qui n'est
pas si en danger que ça vous voyez j'ai
quand même un cavalier qui peut venir
défendre enfin je suis pas complètement
nu quoi 4 bien c'est aussi ce pion FX
donc en fait il peut bloquer les cases
blanches affaibli par exemple si un fond
des trois bah il sera un peu le bec dans
l'eau et on peut pas vraiment aller
attaquer dessus sûr si on avait éffoudé
trois et mettre une batterie ou d'amh5
ça pourrait faire peur mais si vous
vouloir te faire F5 courage 7 et en fait
il défendent tout
et en plus donc peut-être qu'un jour si
les blancs finissent par Roger ben je
pourrais moi aussi peut-être ramener
comme tu l'as dit peut-être cinq fois
une pression sur la colonne GECK ma tour
mon fou quitte après aussi sur la
diagonale G2 donc
intéressant
en tout cas doit gagner donc
il prend les risques un peu plus voilà
c'est normal
[Musique]
après c'est pas mustwin dans cette
partie là
spécialement s'il fait nul mais il
pourra essayer de gagner dans la
prochaine mais il faut qu'il fasse un et
demi sur deux minimum ouais bon après
c'est toujours bien de
prendre ses chances tant qu'on les a
donc de faire le plus de parties
possibles que de tout miser sur une
seule quoi
dépasser les bornes mais je veux dire là
au moins ça a l'air c'est Yoshin
tu menace discrètement un petit
écran de 4 avec un top 3
si défend pas ça
deux parties d'affilée mais c'est toute
défense monstrueuse franchement on n'est
pas genre de sa peau dans les deux
parties bon il y en a une pièce de moins
donc clairement il aurait dû la perdre
mais la deuxième
ben
c'était humainement hyper compliqué à
tenir à défendre et il a été là et tu
vois hyper motivé et il avec une
attitude d'un petit peu à la case fort
en forme on va en parler il est il lâche
rien il est motivé sur toutes les
parties
[Musique]
en fait souvent c'est un truc qui manque
assez jeune joueur quand ils arrivent
c'est leur prépa théorique c'est en fait
déjà arrivé à 200700 quelque chose c'est
hyper dur de base mais une fois que tu
es là en fait tu te fais taper sur la
tête par les mecs à 2780 ou quoi qui eux
sont là depuis longtemps sont installé
qui qui sont mieux préparés avec toi qui
ont déjà une équipe qui voilà et là de
déjà s'entourer bien comme il faut avec
quasim donc quasiment c'est quasiment
que c'était le secondaire de kerwana
pendant longtemps il y avait gagné le
championnat du monde physique en format
élimination j'ai plus en 2004 je crois
bah c'est bien parce que il est hyper
sérieux il est hyper bon et il va lui
apporter une rigueur et l'habituer à ce
travail là pour toute sa carrière quoi
mais
donc qui a été champion du monde fille
il me semble
c'est pas la j'ai pas la date mais
là
des historiens dans le chat
il paraît que c'est mauvais d'après
l'ordi ok on verra
on voit la jauge qui
s'excite alors pourquoi est-ce que
ça ne va pas à ce qu'il y a pas un qui
arrive ouais
[Musique]
il s'en fout complet ça aussi que j'aime
bien chez lui c'est qu'en fait tu vois
franchement la partie par rapport au
match par rapport à la situation bah il
a gagné un et demi sur deux il faut deux
nulles ou un gars pour gagner le tournoi
et bah il va donner un plan quoi
et j'aime bien en fait son approche
il est jeune il veut gagner une tournoi
c'est un peu comme karathon quand il a
reculé la lutte contre un Inde en 2013
quand il a refus de nuls pour être
champion du monde
la partie où il fait la partie qui lui
permet de qui lui permet d'être champion
du monde et ben non on m'a proposé nul
en milieu de jeu
du monde et il a encore mais franchement
tu me donnes une dame d'avance je prends
nul je m'en fous moi
quand même quoi non mais bien sûr mais
mais tu vois et en fait il a dit non et
après quelques fois après ou après nul
tu vois mais
[Musique]
bon il voulait gagner en fait juste
un peu la même enfin je sais pas si il a
refusé mais en tout cas
la dernière onde des candidats quand il
les gagne je crois qu'il a les Noirs
contre gris de choc
en fait nul je suis pour gagner et en
fait il a gagné la partie quoi
juste se faire nul et tu souffles c'est
bon et c'est quand même peut-être ce qui
te différencie les grands champions de
gens comme moi quoi
mais bon j'aurais quand même tendance tu
vois enfin
qui compte je trouve moi c'est de gagner
l'événement c'est pas cinq points et
l'eau
[Musique]
je pourrais pas vous faire flèche mais
on peut parler des couilles il vient de
joker
normalement il veut transférer sa dame
sur l'autre aile après ça c'est
prendrait donc genre
ou plus tard si c'est pas pour
maintenant
et
quoi dire de la position bon le pion F6
est un peu bizarre c'est quoi qu'il en
dise
par rapport à des potions plus
classiques où ils se ranger 7 mais les
Noirs en fait ils ont toujours des
atouts pour les finales parce qu'ils ont
la majorité des dames avec ce A et B qui
peut donner un avion passé donc à terme
et normalement les blancs en fait pour
commencer ça ils sont censés faire
justement eux-mêmes un peu du jeu contre
contre le roi noir ou noir il a fait un
pion passé au centre ou des choses comme
ça parce qu'en gros cette position ça
fait penser un peu
opposition qui avait à la mode à les
grands bidame avec ses prendre des cinq
qui prend des cinq
ou les Noirs échangeaient et un cavalier
4 échec
mais du coup c'est un peu spécial avec
le pion F6 donc peut-être même
bénéficiant avec cette colonne G
de retour tu as sauvé le carton
je sais pas si tu souffles en tant que
un colis d'Amazon je sais même pas ce
que c'est pas encore ouvert et là bon
croquettes pour chat qui
faut changer par rapport à un
lave-vaisselle je crois qu'on a c'est
même pas ce que c'est bon
c'est pas ta commande en fait ben non
c'est le proprio en fait il a il a
acheté un truc pour qu'on change mais
bon je suis à moitié au courant en fait
mais bon mais du coup le chat il voit le
carton
il va ouvrir quoi
bonjour
[Musique]
à tous Emile mois prochain on verra bien
on verra bien il faut que je prenne la
prochaine partie que je joue le 16 juin
donc une partante voilà si c'est si je
gagne quand on 1600
[Rires]
[Musique]
on va être bien
juste tout à l'heure enfin j'ai vu que
les gens n'est pas dans le chat mais je
réagissais l'histoire de la tendinite
c'est pas en cliquant sur ma souris que
je me suis faite c'est un jeu trop
tennis c'est défoncé le bras et du coup
j'ai pris une soirée comme ça pour
mesdames soigner mais c'était pas juste
en cliquant avec la souris je m'étais
fait une transite quand même
pas si accroc
ici c'est un peu faire un truc au centre
un jour peut-être faire un pion dépassé
ou quoi mais ouais ouais bon bah encore
une fois fait billets plutôt pas mal
mais en gros c'est le scénario de chaque
partie pour l'instant donc
donc ça présume de rien pour la suite
mais bon c'est surtout autour des 8 je
sais pas comment tu comptes défendre des
quatre en fait
[Musique]
des fois même du F5 pour ouvrir aussi
il y a des petites choses
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que la prochaine noire
alors quand même plus facile à jouer
mais bon
ça fait trois parties
qu'il avait l'avantage trois fois qui
enfin on va redire qu'il a un bel
avantage mais bon il faut il faut finir
par gagner parce que en fait
la partie je pense c'est la pire tu as
une pièce de plus quoi
et
la deuxième
bah c'était gagnant mais c'était hyper
compliqué et Abdou tartine défense mais
juste monstrueuse et maintenant celle-là
il faut la gagner en vrai si gagne
celle-là bon il voit bien quoi mais dans
le match il joue quand même pas mal
Carona ah bah il joue mieux il joue
mieux mais il perd
ok bon du coup il a pas trouvé comment
le défendre il a donné le pion des mais
encore une fois pour un peu s'activer et
pourquoi pas franchement
ça reste fidèle à ce qu'il fait depuis
tout à l'heure en fait
tu le verras dans une minute
je ne suis pas sur le stream ah d'accord
ce chat
alors que je la connaissais pas je ne
connais pas ce chat donc
du coup elle mange mes câbles enfin elle
mange elle
demande de l'attention et sauf que ben
c'est pas le moment donc carton les fils
les câbles
bon là je suis sur le sur le live mais
je vois toujours pas de chat
et oui ça y est je la vois mais tu te
tâches blanches un peu là en dessous
j'adore les animaux donc
moi j'adore
et en fait je suis plus team chien mais
c'est l'inverse mais ça dépend mais
j'aime pas trop enfin j'aime bien les
chiens mais en fait le problème toujours
dans les sortir tout ça c'est un truc
qui moi qui me gêne
et les chats
[Musique]
quand tu quand il fait une connerie tu
lui expliques rien à alors que le
chien
le chat il fait des câlins quand il a
faim quoi mais sinon tu peux crever
le chien bon ben généralement
c'est différent
et je vais la virer de la chambre
j'ai trois dans les reins quand même
pour venir échanger les dames donc après
je sais ce qui va empêcher d'âme G3
échec et qui permet de mettre la
pression toujours au centre sur F4
[Musique]
stabiliser attaquer tranquille pousser A
et B enfin il y a pas de ça en fait il
te donne le pion en dessin qui se trouve
clou au milieu parce que derrière il a
kiffé tours
il va te faire des trucs enfin il est il
est infernal quoi et sur cavale F4 c'est
quoi le problème
[Musique]
j'ai trois mais je me dame G3 d'un point
il y a toujours
passé ça
je pensais à ça et qu'elle avait les
bougies
pas grand chose après avoir manger là
c'est à dire que cette pression en F7
elle pose problème quand même tu vois
j'ai
jamais mangé la tête un jour un tour C7
devrait être joué pour vraiment menacer
un truc 4
à la maison
voilà je suis là bon
il défend son F7 quoi donc là il va
commencer à menacer des vrais des vrais
histoires peut-être des problèmes
et tout ça
encore une fois
là il faut lui sauter et on veut que le
match dure il faut que
je veux pas
mais il doit gagner en tout cas avec les
Noirs alors peut-être pas forcément
celle-là celle-là ou la prochaine il
doit
mais pour le match c'est bien si gagne
celle-là parce que déjà vu le contenu ça
serait mérité et ça demande une
quatrième partie couteau tirer c'est
intéressant ouais
en psylé même si il fait nul par exemple
avec un trois parties avec un gros
avantage gagner 0 c'est vrai que c'est
un moment faut être réaliste enfin
je veux dire c'est pas dans tous les
dans tous les sports en fait
quand tu as 50 occasions tu marches pas
et tu marques pas pardon c'est pas bon
signe quand tu as 10 balles de bras côté
tu me convertis pas c'est pas bon signe
non plus et aux échecs bah souvent dans
les matchs même de championnats du monde
c'est souvent le mec qui défend le mieux
en fait qui arrive
à tenir quand ça va pas trop la position
et
finir par l'emporter c'est ce qu'a dit
dingue après avoir gagné il a dit ça
arrive pas à gagner bah résiste
et encore plus en face à face en match
évidemment parce que parce que si tu
perds c'est double sanction quoi enfin
alors que là une nulle une pulsion
difficile c'est une sorte de petite
victoire et même moralement tu mets un
coup à l'adversaire quoi
donc donc voilà mais bon pour l'instant
fait il a pas l'air spécialement
démoralisé non
en plus même là pour les blancs trouver
un coup en fait parce que toutes les
pièces
pensent que la plupart des joueurs
perdraient assez facilement avec les
Blancs ici ouais parce que là en fait il
a ça il a s'il enlève t'as plus de tu
vois la cavalier défend le 4 les tours
bon bah il fait tout droit bon peut-être
que ça sert ok il a eu 33
il a pris le 4
donc il encaisse
parce que je pensais que
ils reprennent ce pion on peut pas le
garder alors il aurait pu avoir une idée
bon qui marche pas mais bon juste à dire
c'était tourage 3 la dame elle a qu'une
casse c'est G4 et faire tourger 3 parce
qu'on attaque le kg 6 derrière mais en
fait tu peux aller juste en F5 et tu
descends tout
donc
ça sert à rien de le faire mais bon
a priori il faut juste prendre ce pion
de 4 quoi
et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
ce faux il faut quand même le garder ce
fou je pense à fout des cinq déjà qui
est une idée intéressante
qui peut arriver de partout ouais ouais
mais on se prend un petit G3
par exemple on peut juste montrer l'idée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bon même là il faut encore voir
pénible mais sinon pas loin c'est en
tout cas il y a des idées donc mais fou
des cinq classes ça apparaît trop trop
bizarre donc faut descendre
des trois tu peux le fou
ah c'est très à tous satanien Comme
beaucoup
il mérite
ma qualificatif à ses défenses alors bon
il vous prend quatre trois
parce que chaque là-haut je crois G7
alors combien
mais bon
il y a toujours
un coup ou alors je sais pas quoi
est-ce que une idée c'est comme dame G3
c'est possible aussi
dans son dos
mais on va perdre le code
je perds
qui peut venir c'est n'importe quoi
donc attention celle-là elle risque
là ça a l'air d'être la bonne quand même
je crois
je trouve un coup quoi
parce que c'est pas une menace encore
une fois on a on avait dit qu'on avait
ça
en fait les finales un pion plus mais
comme tu as un doublé
bah ok
en train de faire bien pilonner si je
peux changer les dames peut-être que
c'est ma meilleure France pratique quoi
mais bon les tournois sont hyperactifs
il y a un pion de plus ça a l'air quand
même bien pour moi c'est sympa
est-ce qu'il y a un truc un peu plus
clair
il y a un échec
et dommage 5 qui menace tour D1 et pour
D1
tu es de tu deviens mégapassif quoi
pour le cavalier en plus partie de
marché
mais il y a un problème dans le dans le
dans le setup que tout le monde demande
si l'histoire de qui des Caravana tout
le temps
il vous aime d'ailleurs salut passage
qui lui c'est quoi le rapport entre Fabi
kids et du coup je sais pas est-ce qu'on
a fait mal fait un truc dans le non je
crois pas ou c'est juste que ouais en
fait c'est pas trop pour les enfants
sinon c'est juste ça là c'est la
question là
c'est
un site en fait de cheeseccom c'est une
branche de cheesecom on va dire
justement qui se veut de pour les
enfants donc il y a pas mal de petits
jeux dessus tout ça pour apprendre à
jouer de manière ludique
et voilà
mais tu as pas besoin d'être un enfant
pour le jeu
qui était pas des enfants quoi
[Musique]
non non bah c'est le plus jeune
d'ailleurs je pense de tournoi
alors d'un projet 6
mal à la force enfin malheur bien elle
prend un bon ça ça améliore la structure
mais ça donne des déchets qui et puis
ça a pas de sens
on sait qu'on joue pour le match et pour
en fait notre structure elle est très
bien comme elle est en fait oui a priori
tu passes pas le jour donc c'est pareil
d'avoir
celle là ou l'autre pour toi ça change
rien
mais F5 non Arnaud F5 mais je pense que
par les pâtes ça maintenant
le coup d'avant peut-être en fait
ça donne des cases
qui va arriver
tu t'en fous
tu donnes un cadeau qui qui se retrouve
bloqué par le cabinet
ça va pas trop quoi en résumé
il est pas convaincu à tout à l'air bien
mais
bon en même temps je peux comprendre
qu'il a envie de finir la partie parce
que peut-être qu'il y a regardé dames
c'est 5 échec et je sais pas quoi et
tout rêve 2 un truc des trucs comme ça
j'en sais rien mais bon ça veut dire que
le four a mangé du roi ou du pion et que
bon
peut-être que t'as pas envie moi
d'apprendre à la logique en fait
je peux faire ça
bref
elle a l'air pas mal parce que en fait
les pions doublés ils vont bien protéger
le roi noir tu as trompé le dame qui
arrive
bon ok il doit vraiment calculer un truc
puis ils doivent vouloir finir quoi la
jouer de trop tranquille peut-être parce
qu'il a la mauvaise expérience des deux
parties d'avant ou en fait en jouant les
coups à la main tu as fini et puis
l'autre il te trouve des trucs derrière
les fagots
ça recommence
et tout
enfin le renard qui est un petit peu
enfermé maintenant pour la finale elle
vient plus vers ses cinq quoi
j'aime bien par contre la jauge là elle
fait vraiment la gueule
j'aime bien aussi
le pion h côté noir
Dame des 4 aussi on a fait Billie et
puis peut-être si tu penses à avancer et
là aussi
vu que les blancs sont ficelés ils sont
pas de contre jeu
tu peux prendre ton temps et faire des
trucs cool
j'ai pas vu
pas le problème ouais
ne mangez pas bien 5 donc là 5 B4 c'est
même
on peut trouver une seule idée en fait
la dame elle est bloquée de la tour elle
doit éviter tourner en finale et puis tu
as les pions parce qu'il y a de l'autre
côté donc il faut faire ça tu attaques
tout rêve d'eux aussi qui va arriver
avec la tour en prise tout le temps et
là ouais
mais bon
te faire une menace
il va te faire H5 il va te faire quelque
chose et puis voilà
je le prendrai celui-là
mais ah non tu sais c'est con il y a
trois quatre ça fait autopié
[Musique]
[Rires]
à rester là peut-être même ramener le
roi aussi à manger
[Musique]
je vais prendre l'autre et puis bon
enfin je dois pas sortir de l'auberge
mais
[Musique]
mais bon
donc il a mangé à 4 il a perdu
[Musique]
dans le B3
on sait jamais
je t'aime pour un 20 secondes
mais ça pas une bonne tronche d'avoir le
libérer la dame et la tour arrive à la
colonne enfin je sais pas ce qu'elle
fait en B3 soda
parties mais en chaque partie
il panique pour finir
en fait
non mec
des fois c'est cool aussi ça permet de
commenter quoi juste
[Musique]
il va gagner mais c'est c'est pas bien
d'avoir mis la dame en B3 hors-jeu
là-bas et dans les laisser les blancs se
libérer ou alors une dame en G1 pour
défendre G2 et
s'activait versera donc là encore ça va
d'aller trouver une bonne séquence c'est
bien joué sur
mais il faut tout retravailler
maintenant il faut tout refaire
et Abdou il tient tout quoi depuis tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
qui ne doit pas être
je sais pas mais HK direct
[Musique]
OK
c'était la abandon
il y a des réseaux quoi mais bon tu as
des réseaux de partout
moi je suis content que Fabienne parce
que
[Musique]
bon enfin ça fait trois parties qui
gagnent pas alors qu'à chaque fois il a
mené je trouve qu'un moment donné
aujourd'hui après en général mais là
aujourd'hui sur ce qui montre il joue
mieux aux échecs mais là il a failli pas
la gagner encore enfin je sais pas qui
il arrive à rentrer j'ai un ou quoi mais
peut-être que si les blancs font pas
tour à trois
ça va je sais pas moi
ça va vite fait mais c'est compliqué la
tâche en tout cas
c'est compliqué la tâche donc
prochaine partie d'ici 5 minutes donc le
score c'est 1 et demi 1 et demi il reste
une seule partie dans ce premier set en
cas de victoire d'un des joueurs le
match peut s'arrêter si c'est à toi qui
gagne le match sera terminé parce que il
est en tête dans le tournoi en cas de
victoire de Carvin et ben il gagne le 7
et il y aura un autre set de quatre
parties pareil entre les deux joueurs un
même cadence tout pareil et en cas
d'égalité maintenant et ben on va on va
assister à un avantage Armageddon avec
les temps et les couleurs qui vont se
jouer aux enchères sans vous expliquera
au moins venu
donc avoir un peu ce qui se passe en
tout cas voilà ne peut pas perdre cette
partie s'il veut continuer l'aventure
dans ce tournoi donc karwana aura les
blancs dans la prochaine partie
et et puis donc on va faire une petite
pause je vais vous montrer un petit peu
des pubs ou alors les pubs j'ai tout
fait
un contrat je l'ai fait tout par contre
regardez ce que je vais vous montrer
vous savez que Magnus Carlsen a un
nouveau partenaire et bien c'est
partenaire c'est PUMA avec voilà des
belles chaussures
c'est ça la belle panthère qui s'est
transformée en dame blanche
et
et en vrai c'est pas mal
j'arrive sur le stream avec la mine
tartare peut-être qu'on sait pas
ok alors attends attends
[Rires]
non mais
voilà donc
ces chaussures je crois qu'elles sont en
vente et je crois vers le prix sur le
stream c'était 120 dollars ou euros je
sais plus c'est pas pareil c'est pas
pareil mais je sais plus qui me l'avait
dit ni
voilà mais oui bon c'est pas hors de
prix enfin genre les baskets
et voilà donc si vous voulez progresser
aux échecs vous savez ce qu'il vous
reste à faire acheter du bon pied
et voilà donc je vais quand même vous
laisser une petite pub on revient dans 3
minutes et puis et puis après je pense
que on fera plus de on fera plus de
pause enfin on fera plus de pub derrière
Instagram contrat pub je dois vous
mettre les pubs
qu'on me donne une question commerciale
voilà on est imposé par ça donc pas
merci pour ton commentaire Bruno très
très sympa de ta part en tout cas donc
nous on part en pub et je vous dis à
tout de suite allez à toute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour la partie
donc la quatrième partie de ce set je
vous ai mis la mauvaise évidemment
j'avais une chance sur deux je vais vous
enlever quand même les images
parce que bon ce serait mieux dans les
images on voit mieux ce qui se passe
chez qui donc ça repart sur une
Sicilienne je pense vous baisser un
gains
Fabiano il y a pas dans une changer pour
changer parce qu'il avait plutôt une
meilleure position alors il a changé
cela
il va falloir que 6 ou J6 G6 OK et en
général Détroit tu ramènes la dame à la
maison tu fais quelle idée de KF3
et tu joues des quatre
ils sont en train de jouer ça les tests
de l'éclair
il prépare après tu es pas obligé de le
faire si vite des quatre parce que tu
peux te prendre une pression dessus
justement donc
très vite je sais pas moi je me serais
posé la question mais donc lui connaître
parce que juste tu t'es fait bien que
j'ai 5 quoi donc
bon
je peux entendre H5 ça c'est agréable
quand même de se prendre à 5 parce qu'il
y a toujours de H6 potentiellement c'est
une épine vous la pression sur là et tu
sais pas trop trop comment gérer ça donc
ça son avantage c'est que ça empêche H5
blancs mais par contre ben ça fait de la
position la structure chez les trois
petits points G5 après un Caval 5 par an
je pourrais pas faire un site quoi ces
trois répétition à 115 blanche donc
pourtant pour faire F4 F5 j'y
réfléchirai
[Musique]
ce genre de coups où je sens que regarde
tu veux qui passe
mais en fait comme tu sais qu'il peut
pas le faire et ben tu peux en profiter
en fait et gagner un temps
tu fais ta petite batterie peut-être
parfois justice tu as une idée toujours
etc
comme ça
alors quoi ça c'est la grande question
est-ce qu'on échange ou pas j'ai envie
de dire non mais je suis hyper surpris
du coup moi aussi ça m'a l'air bizarre
mais bon
en fait
ta vie tu essaie de faire mes cinq B4
avec les nerfs
mais je veux dire probablement il a ses
raisons et puis il a reconnaître la
position donc
mais du coup il côté blanc
j'aurais envie de me laisser échanger en
dessin et de prendre du pion
ok alors tout comme ça ouais mais bon
après
est-ce qu'il va me laisser faire je sais
pas mais là ouais parce que je mettrai
qu'il y a un H4 qui va d'autant plus
appuyer F4 F5 et si on fait ça qui m'a
l'air chiant quand il prend un peu les
cases noires quoi mais
ouais après là où je me questionne c'est
déjà sur fruité si je fais Dame des deux
peut-être tu me fais quelques direct
avant de prendre
là
mais du coup maintenant peut-être tu
veux prendre un G5 si tu en as envie
j'ai plus mon cahier H4 et puis je sais
pas trop la position
c'est un peu moins un peu différent quoi
enfin c'est plus c'est plus vraiment ce
que je voulais quoi moi j'aime bien pour
toi parce que j'ai l'impression que ton
foin à un fils il est mal placé
mon plan
on en avait parlé au début que c'était
de toute façon une des idées promenades
et qu'on transfert
[Musique]
j'ai une petite tendresse pour ce coup
je prends ça mais après je peux pas te
garantir que ce soit meilleur que
l'autre ouais
c'est pas ou le mettre mais imaginons un
foie je crois que valait H4 pour jouer
F4 je me tournes aussi intéressant et
donc c'est pas mal et puis même tu peux
même balancer un petit G4
un appui pour le cavalier un jour si
justement tu fais G4 et cahier 4 bons ou
5 et qui passe par des deux quatre ou
j'en sais
pas je le trouve bien
non non en fait c'est intéressant c'est
marrant parce que moi j'aurais fait
carré à l'écran mais c'est un homme
réfléchir
et je leur pour moi c'était même pas un
coup H3
effectivement enfin les deux à mon avis
mais envisageable mais c'est marrant en
tout cas que j'ai même pas eu pas pensé
à ce coup-là alors que
tu as enfin il a pas joué tempo donc
c'est que il est pas prémouvé la reprise
en tout cas
non c'est clair en fait je pense ça me
paraissait pas naturel de base que ça me
paraisse même pas pensé tellement
c'était pas naturel mais maintenant que
tu penses ben écoute c'est un coup que
je commence à bien aimer je trouve que
c'est intéressant
c'est pas mal du tout je prends j'aime
beaucoup j'aime bien l'idée à toi je
crois G2 et peut-être j'ai 4 un truc
comme ça donc c'est un peu à l'arrache
mais prise vous prend enfin et toi
tranquillement
d'amer 4
et bien sûr encore que tu as proposé
aussi ok pourquoi pas j'aime bien j'aime
bien ton idée dans la partie il a joué
je le fais ici
[Musique]
OK
je sais pas si je ferme ou quoi mais je
suis content H3 un jour
donc en fait sur des seins qui veut
qu'il y ait des quatre
il veut les quasiment
normal si tu te repousse genre tu fais
avec ou je sais pas quoi je mets le fond
H3 j'ai l'impression que je suis
beaucoup mieux mais qui est des quatre
comme ça je te bouffe tu rebouffles
et déjà tu fais que 5 ou dame G5 je sais
pas lequel mais un truc comme ça et
ouais c'est pas la fin
c'est pas clair quoi
en fait ça c'était ma petite ce genre de
sacrifice
un pion pour
pour les cases et pour l'initiative et
en plus en maintenant on joue avec avec
un bon cavalier contre un théoriquement
on va dire que c'est un mauvais fou
parce qu'il a une couleur qui prend du
sens il a du mal à bouger bon après bon
toujours non mais
maintenant je vois ça c'est logique web
6 pour échanger plus noir adverse pour
que sur les cases noires mais à
ce moment-là j'étais pas j'étais pas à
jour de l'idée qu'il avait quoi
ça va être même E5 tu dis oui bon je
fais des cinq il dégage quoi ils sont
cavalier donc tu mets est-ce que tu
penses
ouais c'est sûr il avait des gens
en tout cas pour le jeu aussi vite c'est
qu'il connaît en fait et que il sait que
sur des 4 ce sera ça sa réaction
et du coup bah j'ai peut-être pas envie
de faire des cinq mais
je sais pas mais c'est vrai que j'ai
cinq faibles maintenant enfin oui
[Musique]
c'est pas très agréable
j'aime pas ça quoi
tu aimes pas ce que je lui ai proposé
[Musique]
on va voir un peu plus faible ouais je
vais perdre mais oui en fait on doit on
doit arriver à tenir quand même
pas horrifié par la position
parce que j'aimais pas moi j'adore
j'aime bien la position blanche et
en fait très vite tes contrats de te
dire ok déjà quand je fais pour pas
perdre question sur quoi tu penses nul
parce que
parce que il y a plus le choix je crois
qu'il m'embête je peux doubler les tours
je peux
lancer oui tu peux faire autre chose
de ce genre mais bon ok peut-être 5
peut-être même les noirs qui jouent un
peu
la tour elle est active le pion des il
va être faible un jour vous tombez un je
perds-toi bien j'aime pas trop il y a
même une B5 qui peut arriver un jour
en fait je pense que chaque camp a des
pions un peu faible c'est ce qui peut
être faible
à un moment donné
il doit se débarrasser de toutes ces
faiblesses bon c'est pas cool
et pourquoi
triste
c'est un peu
à Valence il y a quelques semaines et
j'avais une position du même type sauf
que moi j'avais dame et tout renversé
sauf que moi j'ai pas de prénom
contraintes
il avait une dame en
quelque chose
c'était nul en fait les mecs dans une
position
en Allemagne
le tour non non
le mec il m'a proposé deux fois nul dans
la partie une fois du coup et l'autre
fois au bout de 20 coups
et fermer
5 lui aussi il y a d'autres mecs à 5h05
et là j'ai les blancs et je sais que la
pompe d'après j'aurais les Noirs contre
un genre à 2003 50
[Musique]
et à la fin presque engueulé enfin pas
engueuler mais il m'a dit que limite
c'est un manque de respect d'avoir
refusé nul parce que la pression est
égale et alors
bon mais une position où il y a que moi
qui peut gagner j'ai 4000 32
et
quand c'est égal non mais tu as le droit
d'enfiler en fait
[Musique]
quand je peux avoir quand j'avais
mais bon même si c'était moins bien tu
as le droit
en fait peut-être je sais pas moi je
m'en fous de sa vie et de ce que font
les gens et peut-être qu'en fait quand
de tournoi et ben les mecs qui gagnent
tout et après les ondule entre eux pour
la suite
il a 55 ans il a 22 ans 22 70 quoi
[Musique]
de pépère et je comprends bien hein moi
j'ai envie de le mettre en fait aussi je
serais content mais meilleur que toi en
fait donc je vais te battre quoi
simplement
mais je peux comprendre mais sauf que
moi je suis pas du tout c'est la partie
qui est bon je crois qu'il a mis la dame
en
ce soir
et on pensait
plus que tout on l'a mis
[Musique]
à voir peut-être sur là il faut que
c'est calculer aussitôt
C8 attention que si Fabien ne perd cette
partie le match est fini
il est en train de la perdre en fait bah
il est en train de la perdre
je sais pas trop le renard il est assez
tranquille et
donc il va falloir se battre pour la
sauver et pas évident quoi et il a 7
minutes devant la pendule
donc
on répète
j'ai tourné
qui a assez sympa bon je me place
important alors ça je fais ça
et tes pièces sont très mal placé en
fait là-haut après c'est que la dame
devient attachée la défense de la tour
et ben elle peut pas revenir en F4
défendre par exemple oui tu peux pas
revenir parce que je mange et je mange
là
attends il y a eu de 1m4 là il s'est
rendu compte que ça perd en fait
mais là cette partie ce serait un
miracle
il arriverait à Y
bon il peut peut-être encore la sauver
mais bon
au final
je t'ai fait des éloges sur ce coup mais
en fait il est très bien sauf que il y a
eu 5 qui est trop fort
[Musique]
on se l'a dit je sais pas Fabi était pas
obligé de faire 5 et de perdre des seins
et tout mieux non plus
et là en fait même l'option sera H4 on
sera quand même dans la merde on aura un
purement pour rien quoi
la prédiction humaine
parce que moi je suis modo comme toi en
fait c'est ce qu'on me faire il est pas
en ligne
à la fin ok mais c'est moi qui ai déjà
le stream c'est pas parce qu'on va faire
là donc tu peux mettre un robot à faire
il le verra pas
c'est le sachet c'est lui hein tu veux
pas on lui fait très mal on met un coup
d'épée quoi
[Musique]
pas mal
on peut même faire tout F5
c'est la partie 7
et 5
et là il peut venir défendre la Tour
Eiffel c'est tous les cas c'est bien
joué encore hein
en plus attaquer F2 elle défendra sur la
grande diagonale
encore 8 minutes 40
de voir de voir son interview là pour
cette partie voir jusqu'à quelle couille
il était un peu dans de prépa je pense
il a l'air de la position il avait l'air
enfin
en tout cas elle avait les idées
clairement mais
[Musique]
écoute moi
passif peu de temps
je vois pas je vois pas comment il
pourrait survivre ici notre ami à une
déconnexion ah bah oui
ça peut arriver ça
arrivera
[Musique]
il avait des problèmes de connexion
du coup on a un peu le même genre
position que la partie d'avant ou c'est
le même rapport mental dame tout là avec
un pion de plus sur l'aile dame et des
pièces festives à la défense donc Fabi
avait gagné quand il avait été côté noir
comme ça
on va voir si maintenant on fait de même
pour geste
[Musique]
le problème c'est qu'on a
sécurité souvent en fait pour avoir une
chance de nul tu joues pour le Perfect
tu l'as fait briller mais là je vois pas
trop ce qu'on va pouvoir faire c'est ta
raison
C4 tu le défends et
tant pis il peut tenter finalement
caractère pas si facile mais en plus je
crois pas mal il a battu Magnus avec un
zizi cette année dessus
juste en début de partie on peut pas
trop le faire et trop de pièces légères
pour gagner des temps dessus mais quand
la partie avance si on peut y aller faut
pas se priver
ça dépend où est-ce qu'il est mais deux
c'est ça va être
B5 je pense oui mais je pense que ça va
être le coup de 5 ans
et juste ma question si on prend du pion
de la dame
et j'en sais rien en fait c'est une
religion
est-ce que c'est important
possible c'est juste pas possible de
manger ça je pense en tout cas il a pas
le choix en fait mais bon c'est pas un
bon signe quoi
je vais faire ça renouveler la menace et
puis là si tu manges pas
la nulle quand il veut
mais bon
en fait c'est vrai que tout à l'heure
j'avais dit que les pions ça dépendent
dans quel sur quel est ils étaient et
c'est vrai que là de ce côté là il y a
plus de pion passé en fait donc
[Musique]
pour le matin
pas de maths encore
mais bon tu menaces
[Musique]
ça a l'air pas mal
donc là il y a pas de matin vous voyez
je crois pas
[Musique]
j'ai appuyé
madame verset 4 avec les marches
en plus donc ça fait cool
mais bon
il se passe pas
le moins de chance au blanc
c'est le coup qui a donné le moins de
chance
[Musique]
parce que ben
je me place en fait
je peux même pas je peux pas faire
ranger 4 je dois faire j'ai pas le choix
ou alors manger là
[Musique]
par exemple
là j'étais plus je mets de mon roi
[Musique]
G7
s'il y avait pas de pions ici j'aurais
pu faire un petit non ça marche même pas
le temps
et là il va aller à attends j'ai 5 et là
c'est abandon abandon de carvana avec
matin par avant J5 en fait c'est beau
c'est pas ton pion a tu peux essayer de
MC1 pour faire Pat mais il te fait quand
même dame G5 et te mettre avec un pion
ici
cloué mais attention que si c'est un
champion et bah il y a dans le 5 échec
et sur dame prend rayon X
jolie très jolie
un peu ratées enfin surtout les deux
premières parties de famille il a pu
être faire mieux et par contre dans
cette quatrième partie c'est
complètement mérité
ça a été une masterclass de la part
d'Abdou qui a fait
je vais vous montrer qu'un petit braquet
de finale pour qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
en fait
et voilà un champion champion à regarder
il a commencé en bas des quarts de
finale il a battu jus de Moussa 2 et
demi-heure et demi après carvana un et
demi de et demi il a battu van Forest et
demi et il a rebattu en finale karena 1
et demi à 2,5
fois plus à chaque fois que je change de
d'anglais plus te voir
donc en fait tu fais donc toi comme tu
es modo tu dois faire
slash
bravo à ceux qui ont trouvé qui vont
gagner des points chênes bravo
cette prédiction et qui a parié dessus
et qu'il et qui
et qui ne pouvait plus du coup la
valider
ouais incroyable incroyable Abdou en
franchement
tout le long du tournoi des grandes
qualités défensives de ressources dans
les pression pas évidentes aujourd'hui
et puis quand ça fait du bien jouer la
dernière là il était au rendez-vous donc
chapeau impressionnant en tout cas
impressionnant et puis écoute ben nous
on va s'arrêter là pour aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on se revoit pas
[Musique]
je souhaitais un bon top 16 allez parce
qu'on peut on va essayer et puis bah
ouais tranquille moi je te regarderai et
puis bah écoute ben à bientôt merci à
tous d'avoir su le stream c'était cool
donc passez une bonne une bonne fin de
semaine un bon week-end et nous on se
retrouve à partir de mardi pour le début
du Norway chaise donc un gros tournoi
avec
fille et puis
il y aura il y aura pas mal de de
ah ça va être beau hein ça va être aller
ah c'est pas mal je leur plateau de de
mêler les jeunes prometteurs avec
des boss du circuit entre guillemets et
donc
c'est sympa de voir un peu ce qu'il
entra et
donc ouais c'est un beau tournoi à
suivre parce que des fois moi j'étais un
peu lassé des tournois où est toujours
les mêmes joueurs c'est toujours pareil
pareil pareil là au moins tu as des
nouvelles têtes et ok c'est un peu c'est
cool quoi c'est clair moi je suis
complètement d'accord et en plus quand
tu les invite et ben ils sont là et ils
font des supers résultats donc ça montre
clairement qu'ils ont leur place et que
c'est la nouvelle génération qui qui
rend bouscule d'aller les légendes tu
vois toutes les tous les rognons les
sauts enfin voilà quoi donc en tout cas
hyper cool donc merci à tous
moi je vous souhaite à bientôt à mardi
du coup à partir de mardi vous aurez
pareil le nord-ouest on serait parti
lente donc il y aura plus de choses à
dire en plus de contenu et puis je sais
pas encore avec qui je serai accompagné
mais je voilà donc merci à tous merci à
toi Fab je vous dis à très bientôt on va
partir avec un petit raid
tu veux le faire toi comme un grand
alors tu fais slash Fred espace
et après tu veux tu peux raide échec
avec un S c'est tout à fait amateur ama
TER il y a pas de
pluriels
et plusieurs années ok donc tu peux la
raid
je suis rentré et puis ça va se faire
tout seul
il y a plus qu'à attendre ou valider
et tu vois c'est facile je suis pas sûr
ça a marché si ça va marcher je pense je
le regarde
mon téléphone sur la vu que je suis pas
sur le enfin j'ai l'Obs mais c'est un
peu compliqué là j'ai pas la mais
vraiment normalement ça va partir
quasiment tout seul tu vois rien sur ton
écran moi je veux absolument rien mais
bon je pense à partir faudrait que je le
vois là sur mon téléphone mais là je le
vois pas encore
j'ai mal fait
[Musique]